there are three different rows of
diamond pick one of these diamond blocks
this one now i want you to dig down one
block
you just made one thousand dollars dig
down another block
you just made another thousand dollars
so here's the thing somewhere along the
way
there's a pit of lava and if you fall in
the lava
you lose all your money if you want dig
another block
but there could be lava under it so now
you have three thousand dollars
four thousand dollars five thousand
dollars six thousand dollars
seven thousand oh my god thousand eight
nine dollars
there's lava somewhere oh no
oh no dude you went so fast you didn't
even
think about it alex you're in the middle
of a giant platform
and here's an efficiency five pickaxe
you just made one dollar mine another
block you just made two dollars
every single stone block you mine you
will get one dollar
and there's fifty 000 of them let's see
how many
oh my gosh wait the efficiency five
mine's that fast i thought it was slower
oh my gosh we're gonna get so much money
from this bro final words before we go
to our next contestant uh sup to mr
beastgaming and all these other channels
vouch heart vouch agreed thank you
up next we have this parkour course on
example
if you can get to the end of this orange
parkour course i'll give you 500
okay easy i think we can all agree
pretty easy
now if you get to the end of this yellow
parkour course
i'll give you two thousand dollars but
if you fall you get nothing
do you want to do it yes i want to try
it so you're risking your 500
okay defenses for two grand hey this
this one was pretty easy
pretty easy oh yeah yeah so you have won
two thousand dollars so far do you want
to risk it for
five thousand dollars if you finish this
green course if you fall you get nothing
you can walk away with two grand right
now though i wanna try it okay
let's see it he's focused the
determination the skill
five thousand dollars think of all the
mac and cheese you could buy
one more jump don't miss it nice nice
let's go
you are now on the final level the blue
level do you want to risk your five
thousand dollars for
ten thousand dollars if you get to end
of this course uh
no no no no oh good congratulations on
your five
thousand dollars what are you gonna buy
with it i might upgrade my pc
with this honestly buy parkour lessons
maybe you could have got more money
[Music]
alex buddy how's it going i'm making so
much money right now
according to our command you for nine
one thousand hundred 1972 blocks so far
holy cow that's like not even close to
50 000. yeah maybe it's because you're
just standing around bro get to mining
next place this is vapor if you jump off
this diving board
and water bucket on that block i'll give
you a thousand dollars because it's not
that tall
all right all right if you climb this
ladder and jump onto that block i'll
give you
three thousand dollars if you climb this
ladder
all the way up there and water bucket on
that block i'll give you nine thousand
dollars take your pick
paper go big or go home let's go this
man's insane look how long it's taking
you to climb this look at the
determination
you know the precision you're gonna have
to have i got him
nine thousand dollars on the line let's
go
[Music]
bye bye you aren't even close
you didn't even hit the block i thought
it was directly underneath
i don't want you to walk away with
nothing so i'll give you a shot at the
kitty jump maybe i am just a child
this one's for a thousand dollars
he gets a thousand let's go you're
insane
you didn't get nine thousand dollars but
you got a thousand all right that's
awesome
this is zero night hello you could walk
away with five smackeroonies if you
decide correctly oh that's a lot of
stuffy movies would you rather face 100
zombies or 100 creepers
creepers oh oh man in this chest
is all your gear wasting no time at all
you seem very efficient i'm a symphony
super intense minecraft player
oh my goodness that's my boy
you're gonna take my job stop ten
nine i started too high one spawn the
creepers
let's go oh my god whoa oh
what he's in a good position now you got
the high ground
oh oh no oh no zero zero please
oh dear i really want you to win five
grand come on zero you got this yeah
you're doing great
oh i'm lagging this is bad you're doing
okay you're doing okay
it's okay the armor calculations are all
right he's calculating you have to use
the creepers to kill the creepers
oh my god he's cranking him he's doing
good
oh man he did the meme he's basically
chris at this point oh wait i just
realized there's only one creeper left
there's only one creeper
i was gonna build suspense but i don't
need to because you already won
congratulations congratulations you no
longer have zero dollars you have five
thousand dollars hey five thousand
dollars night
wait how old are you zera 11. you're 11
and you just won
five grand what a goat zero night can
you please sing these lyrics
i got a number one victory
just for that zero you're getting six
thousand dollars let's go
send me your mom's number on discord
we're going on to the next bid
alex it has been thirty minutes wow
so far alex you've mined four thousand
two hundred and fifty blocks what's
going through your mind
i don't know i'm just trying carefully
in my head like how efficient i am at
buying these blocks
alex if you can guess who's directly
standing behind you i'll give you a
potion of swiftness
uh chandler turn around
wait taylor don't leave no it was
chandler here's swiftness
now answer this question and i'll give
you haste do you like carl
yes this next would you rather is a
little bit different
if you look inside this chest you'll see
a block that says split
or steel yes and creeper if you look
inside your chest same thing split
or steal got it yeah i have ten thousand
dollars in cash and if you both select
split
then you each get five thousand dollars
a lot of money
yeah if one of you selects split and the
other selects steal
the person who picks steel gets 10 grand
if both of you pick
steel you both get nothing they don't
even get to talk to each other we're
going to talk to kaiju first
all right so kaiju well well well you
can select split or steal and you can't
talk with creeper i'm so scared i don't
know what to do like when we talked
together we had a really nice time
i don't know based on your conversations
with him you think he's a nice guy
i'm going to go for it i'm believing
don't trust him
so if you do steal and he does split you
steal the 10 grand from him
yep that's that's what you want they're
scaring me okay i'm going split
what a good man okay so creeper kaiju
has already made his decision we will
not reveal
what it is now you need to decide are
you splitting or are you stealing
yeah we were talking a lot before and uh
yeah
and in all these instances he was a nice
guy correct yeah
if you think he's a nice guy and he's
gonna pick split shouldn't you pick
steel and just
win the 10 grand are you a nice guy is
the question
i don't feel that it's right especially
given you know just met
the guy that i should make a bad
impression i want to you know what if
you stole the 10 grand and only gave him
a thousand
kaiju what do you think he picked i
don't know i'm starting to have second
guesses now
all right server drop the wall
congratulations you both just won
five thousand dollars they tried to talk
to me but uh
yeah yeah [ __ ] to it holy oh my god i'm
shaking right
now they're gonna be friends forever i
love you dude
mr fish i have a bow and some arrows all
right
i can't cross this golden line right
here you can go wherever you want and
every second you stay alive i'll give
you a hundred bucks that is a lot of
money
it's you versus me and the boys i'd get
running go every second you get 100
bucks
all right check it just missed i haven't
hit him once
does anyone hit him no he's probably
already oh dude you've already made like
a thousand bucks
i hit him ahead of my head of my atom
don't let him reject no leaving
oh hey i got him i got him jimmy with
the ending
you survived 18 and a half seconds which
means you made 1850.
let's go let's go for round two oh
chris come help i hit him ahead of my
head am i at him one shot one shot
got him we did it all right well you
only made an extra 400
that time congratulations next
contestant what is up x quality
so you just won ten thousand dollars in
cash
thank you but there's a little twist
we're gonna spawn 200 skeletons and
every time you get shot by a skeleton
you lose a hundred dollars whatever
money you have left when they're all
dead
you keep except servers spawn the
skeletons
try not to lose your ten thousand
dollars minus five hundred
six hundred eight hundred nine hundred
oh my
gosh you're losing so much money oh the
skellies are attacking each other
exquility you can do this
you've been hit 27 times you're making
good progress you're halfway there well
they're starting to fight each other a
little bit
all right if you really get things
together you can walk away five grand in
cash
come on there's like 10 left you look
like a porcupine right now can he clean
up without getting hit
come on two one
okay congratulations you got hit
48 times and lost 4 800 which means you
just walked away with five thousand
two hundredths macaroonies yeah i don't
know what to say what are you gonna do
with the five thousand dollars uh i'm
gonna help my sister wear a baby she
just got a baby like two weeks ago
where'd she get it
you know just for that we're gonna bump
it up to six thousand dollars nice
what up alex so how many blocks do you
think you mind
uh 6 000 plus i think you mind
8 230 which is just below 10
000 so we're going to round up and say
10 000.
congratulations little alex boy you are
now big alex boyd
hey thank you for watching everybody
goodbye